we continue to follow that breaking news
new developments in the murder case of
review journal investigative reporter
jeff gearman right now metro police
still searching the home of clark county
public administrator rob telus in
connection to this crime 8 news now
reporter vanessa murphy joining us live
now at charleston and wallapie to give
us the very latest vanessa
heather we just saw sheriff joe lombardo
leave the scene after speaking with
investigators and we do know that robert
tellis has been with investigators while
they search his home here now a couple
of key things to note jeff german had
done several stories in the review
journal on public administrator robert
telus and problems within his office
telus then lost the democratic primary
yesterday we showed you video of a
vehicle police were looking for the
suspect vehicle this gmc yukon our
photojournalist shot video of a vehicle
just like that one here earlier at the
home of telus metro police also released
video of the suspect we showed that to
our viewers yesterday metro police said
the suspect had been casing the area so
again police are talking with telus
he is with investigators as they search
his home this is an active situation an
active scene an active investigation
we're going to stay on top of it and
bring you the latest reporting live
vanessa murphy 8 news now